I'm a train wreck
bachelorette jo Jo Fletcher explains all
those tears
I gotta tell you girl on most of these
episodes you shed a few tears a few
tears let's just be honest I'm a train
wreck
I caught up with Jojo at the men tell
all taping in Los Angeles where she
addressed online chatter about her
waterworks or lack thereof you know
what's so funny to when people are like
I don't see any tears I'm like are you
kidding me you can thank my makeup
artist then because she did a real good
real good job touching it up I notice
you're very careful you like touched
your I've you're like I don't wanna mess
oh ok so sometimes I okay I have to tell
you guys I had a leaky eye my allergies
got so bad towards the end that I kept
having to rub this one eye sometimes it
was both but I mean if it wasn't me
crying my eyes out it might have been
just the allergies getting to me oh why
what do you have to say to the people
who say you cried too much are you just
a crier
oh you know what I think they would cry
just as much it's I'm emotional it's
hard no one will understand it
and I felt you know saying if I so hard
what can I say another thing viewers
have noticed Jojo keeps doing is
bringing up her ex bachelor Ben Higgins
Ben told me everything that I wanted to
hear Ben and Lauren getting their own
reality show
oh that's so it's so exciting I just
talked to Lauren the other day and I
mean I'm excited for them it's exciting
and I'm just excited to watch it and see
how it plays out